As we hinted before, this special syntax in HTML is called a tag.
It's kind of like a price tag you might attach to a shirt or another item you're buying.
This modifies nearby text and tells you how to interpret it,
whether you can wash it or not in a machine, how much it costs,
whether or not it should be bolded or underlined--that sort of thing.
Another super common kind of tag is the anchor tag,
which is used to add hyperlinks to webpages.
In some sense this is the defining characteristic of what it means to be a webpage.
Here I've written a fragment of HTML that includes such an anchor tag.
It begins here, but unlike the relatively simple bold and underline tags,
it has an argument.
This means pretty much the same thing it did when we were talking
about functions in Python or math.
Here the argument or my sine function is pi.
Here the argument or modifier for my anchor tag is href equals.
This stands for hypertext reference--the target of this link.
Here I've given a string that is a URL, a web address.
Hypertext transfer protocol google.com.
This text in the middle is often rendered in blue with an underline, although it doesn't have to be.
Then over here we're ending the anchoring tag. Let's see how this plays out.
Here I've the old "Eric Blair was really George Orwell" text,
but I've added a new sentence--"Click here for a link to a webpage."
Right after the anchor starts, the text is rendered in a slightly different color.
If we were to click on it, you can potentially see down in the lower left
that it goes to google.com.
Just to break this down, if this is a fragment of HTML,
then the words "Click here and now" will all be drawn on the screen.
This syntax marks the beginning of the anchor tag.
This syntax, left angle bracket slash a right angle bracket,
marks the end of the anchor tag.
This part in here is the argument of the tag.
It contains extra information for things that are more complicated
than simple bold or underline.